before we say goodbye we like to play a
quick round of truth or dare
all right uh we have sean bunch hi sean
hi
hi drew hi ross how y'all doing i love
your name oh thank you my mother gave it
to me
um so i
and my boyfriend are a big fan of yours
on drag race oh thank you you're talking
to me thank you
thank you so much
you know it's my daughter olive's
favorite show it is oh she loves it well
we all love it at our house i love it
too i can't believe i get to do it well
i have a truth for both of you okay so
my truth today is what would both of
your drag names be oh do we get judged
on our drag names the way we get judged
on our pet names not today
okay
um oh i you know people ask me that i
never have a good answer for that i have
never i've actually never done drag
before
um yet um
could i just go with nelly
i mean you could go with nelly but i
mean uh do you have one for me a better
one i mean what about
uh
rossay all day
or how about uh farah rossett oh
sarah rossett
i mean so good that i was like
[Music]
there we go pharah how about for you
drew um motley drew
oh
i mean i am rebellious yeah
um what about you sean bunch you got one
for you oh yeah uh well i'm miss ruby
troutman
shantae you stay oh
yeah well done
[Music]